um
good evening
we we had today a video conference
with uh the head of state and the head
of government
uh and with the president
of the euro group and the president of
the european central bank
affirmed the need to work together and
to do
everything necessary to tackle the
crisis and its consequences
on the four priorities identified the
first
limiting the spread of the virus we
endorsed
the guidelines proposed by the
commission on border management
we need to ensure passage of medicines
foodstuffs and goods and our citizens
must be able to travel to their home
countries
adequate solutions for cross-borders
workers
will be found to limit the spread of the
virus globally
we agreed to reinforce our external
borders by applying a coordinate
temporary restriction of non-essential
travel
to the eu for a period of 30 days
based on the approach proposed by the
commission
the student item providing medical
equipment
we welcomed the decision taken by the
commission to adopt
a prior authorization for its support of
medical equipment
and we support it the commission effort
to engage with the industry
to run joint public procurements and to
purchase
of protective equipment through the
civil protection framework
this second item is very
essential we need to make important
progress
in the next days and in the next weeks
on this important topic
the third topic promoting research we
encourage the efforts made to support
research
such as the advisory group on provide 19
and we stressed the need to share
information and to develop
a vaccine and make it available to all
those in need
we invite also the member states and the
commission to support
european companies in that respect
the fourth point tackling socio-economic
consequences
we endorsed the eurogroup statement and
invited the euro group to continuously
and closely monitor
economic and financial developments and
to adapt without delay
a coordinated policy response to the
rapidly evolving situation
and we supported the various initiatives
taken by the commission
in the areas of the single markets such
as
the adaptation of the state aid rules
and the use of the flexibilities
provided for
in the stability and growth pact and
recourse to the eu budget
the union and its member states will do
whatever it takes
to address the current challenges to
restore confidence
and to support a rapid recovery for the
sake
of our citizens the fifth
point is also very important and that's
why the high representative
was also also presented active
in this for this conference video
conference
we committed to coordinate among our
embassies
and the eu delegations in third
countries and high representatives and
the open external action service
will support in this regard will jointly
arrange repatriation of eu citizens
when necessary and possible and make use
of the union civil protection mechanism
additionally you funding for such joint
operations will be
mobilized
[Music]
in the videos
thank you charles um it was indeed very
good to see
how the member states strongly endorsed
the package we have brought forward over
the last
days it's the package on borders the
package on the economy
on the joint public procurement
we have and of course including the
research part
so it was good to see that was full
approval
on the side of the member states to go
into a few
of these topics more deeply indeed one
of
the first topics was the implementation
of
of the temporary entry restrictions on
the external
borders so we got a lot of support by
the member states
it's up to them now to implement um
they said they will immediately do that
this is good
um so that we have a unanimous
and united approach what the external
borders are concerned
there was a lot of approval what our
proposal
is concerned a big topic today were of
course
also the internal borders and
consequently the blockage is there and
here
it is absolutely crucial that we unblock
the situation
because we know that too many people are
stranded within the european union
and have a problem to go back home they
have to
be supported to go back home and of
course
we have a lot of traffic jam of lorries
transporting goods the flow of goods
has to be swift we need these goods for
the functioning
of the internal market and therefore
there was a broad welcome
uh concerning the guidelines we issued
yesterday that were discussed yesterday
in the
council of the ministers of internal
affairs
so big approval for the so-called green
lanes
fast track lanes mainly for the flow of
goods
but we have also to make sure that the
commuters can go back and forth where
they live or where they work
there was an impressive example from
luxembourg who
uh the the prime minister of luxembourg
said very clearly that's for luxembourg
essential
that they have the commuters coming back
and forth because the majority of the
health workers in the hospitals
are living either in france or in
germany and have to commute swiftly
and it cannot take them hours to go to
work or back home
so it's important that we fix that
situation here
same goes for the lorries my
commissioners are in constant contact
with the respective ministers of the
different member states
that we solve that now we have the
guidelines there was approval for the
guidelines
and they have to be implemented now
one point that was very positive
we had been asked to set up
a group of experts virologists or
epidemiologists
to give us advice and we had the first
meetings
and it was good to see that they fully
approve
in their recommendation what the
measures for the term is social
distancing is concerned
so it's absolutely correct on this
evidence-based and scientific
based approach to have these measures
to slow down the spread of the virus to
make sure that we have no public
gatherings that
universities and schools are closed that
entertainment
places are closed because we want people
in this case not to have contact with
each other so that we can
reduce the speed of the spread of the
virus and therefore
reduce the pressure on the health sector
and the patients that have to be treated
we launched today public procurement for
gloves and
masks and yesterday for respiratory
ventilators
24 member states are participating that
is good
the companies have now six days to
tender
and then the member state can
immediately
sign up the contract the day after the
tender is closed
within the next six days we are working
also with the industry throughout europe
to ramp up the production of these
scarce goods
so concerning the personal protective
equipment but also the ventilators that
are desperately needed
and finally on friday indeed we launched
a strong
economic package this tool was
unanimously
endorsed by the member states friday
fields already
quite a while ago because since
friday we see that things have gotten
even more serious
the situation has worsened the economic
situation is extremely serious and
therefore
all the measures that have been taken on
the health side which are correct to
contain the virus
we see that they have a huge impact on
our economy
this is an external shock and it hits
the whole world
we have never had that before the enemy
is
a virus and now we have to do our uh
most to protect our people and to
protect our economies
since last friday we are working on all
fronts to deliver on the ground
first we are right now finalizing the
new temporary framework for state aid
that will provide very high flexibility
to member states
to support for example their companies
second it was good to see that yesterday
the euro group welcomed our readiness to
activate the general escape clause we're
working on it and we'll come forward
with a proposal
to the council in the next days and let
me stress once more
we are ready to do everything that is
required
we will not hesitate to take additional
measures
as the situation evolves thank you
we'll take a couple of questions in the
room and we've received a lot of
questions of course
virtually but first yes politico
we'll take a question from you
sarah wheaton with politico um president
vanderlian um today you posted a video
on twitter
i'm talking about aid to a company
working on a vaccine for coronavirus and
you said i hope that with the support we
can have a vaccine on the market perhaps
before autumn
um regulators and public health experts
in both the u.s and europe have
consistently said it will take at least
a year to a year and a half to have a
widely available
vaccine and that's even speeding up the
normal regulatory process so
what makes you think there's a
possibility that we would have a vaccine
by autumn and uh is there a
responsibility for
for um commission officials like
yourself to
maintain realistic expectations in the
public yes
the fact that uh other countries tried
to buy that company show
that they are the front runner in the
research
highly acknowledged and they are working
on a pattern
that has already been approved and gone
through
specific processes that are necessary so
they are highly specialized in this
field and
it's their prediction that
they might be able towards fall
to have the possibility to have a
vaccine that
is fighting coronavirus it was very
important for us it's a european company
we wanted to keep it in europe it wanted
to stay in europe it was very important
to give him
to give it the necessary funding and
that has happened
yesterday when we had this conversation
with all due respect i asked them and
they said
they acknowledge the process usually
takes years it would be up to regulators
to speed it up
have you gotten any guarantees from
regulators can you give us any specific
information about what
is leading you to to make a prediction
that differs from
from regulators yes i think as we are in
a severe crisis we all see
that we are able to speed up any of the
processes that are slow
normally and take a lot of time and are
very bureaucratic
we all know goes for the public
procurement for example
right now too we have processes that
normally are slow
are difficult but we have the means to
speed them up
and here too i think if we focus on the
essential
we're talking about a crisis that
will not only affect heavily the
european union but we know it will
spread throughout the world
and just imagine that it goes into other
regions of this world
what it means to have a potential
vaccine
so this is of utmost importance for us
yes next question
thank you
okay thank you thomas
a question um to the president
have president of the commission have
you received any assurances today
from the polish government that it is
going to change
its policy at the border um specifically
stopping people from the baltic
republics
that want to cross through
and have you received assurances
from any government that with
the closing of external borders they are
willing
to take back some of the unilateral
controls they have introduced
in the schengen area these past days
thanks
we had a good discussion with
the member states on the problems at the
border
also specific borders and member states
it was good to hear that i had several
phone calls with
the polish prime minister and it was
good to hear that
he said to the member states that they
are working at the moment being
first of all on the fast track on the
green lanes and to make sure that there
is a corridor
that is important for the lorries and
that they are working hard
also on giving assistance
to the people that are stranded on the
german side for example people coming
from estonia or latvia or lithuania
so that they can go through in a
corridor through
poland so it's absolutely necessary
that something happens but i'm positive
that there will be a movement and a
positive change over the next days
i have a question and yeah this
yes um i think it is important now to
implement the regime on the external
border
i told you and you said it too that we
have an intensive discussion about the
internal border measures that are
hampering not only the single market and
our economy but also difficult for the
labor market for example
with those who are commuters and
we have published the guidelines the
guidelines got a lot of
backing so i think the first step will
be that we ease
the tension in those regions where
internal borders have been borrow
measurements have been put up
in general so that they are more
flexible and they
are more targeted on
leaving leaving the leaving the way
to the flow of goods and those people
who have to cross the border urgently
but i think it will take quite a while
still till
we reach the lifting of the internal
border it was an intensive discussion
i think it was uh it was clear at the
end of the discussion
that we have to be very careful with our
single market
and this is the most economic economy
in the economy it's the most precious
instrument we do have so it's of ut most
importance
that we keep it going and keep it up
because
it is of essential importance
mainly being in such a crisis as we are
right now
president
videos have a question from the new york
times as well from martina stevies
president of the council and of the
president to the president of the
commission can you clarify which
countries
agree to go ahead with the broader
issues measures
namely was it to 27 minus ireland plus
non-eu
schengen
i take that one um so
we got a lot of approval of
member states actually it was
uh none of them who
up uh was negative on this proposal
but we know that at the moment being the
uk
is not planning on
implementing external border
restrictions
as far as i understand today they advise
their people uh not to travel abroad
this is as far as i got from the news uh
the state of play in the uk at the
moment being
and of course this goes then for island
too because we have a
common travel zone important is
that the uk citizens are eu citizens so
i think
we still have to repeat that because we
are in the transition
uh phases so for for the uk citizens and
of course northern ireland things stay
as they are
i have one last question from a lot of
news outlets
[Music]
in europe
[Music]
thank you very much
so
[Music]
you